yeah sure
um what do you think about if you had to
give advice to people coming to LA
because all we do is see people getting
robbed on on social media now this is
something that has always happened out
here since the pandemic since the PPP
and the EDD has dried up I feel like
yeah it's escalated and now there's
social media so we see it a lot more but
how would you advise people to move
around out here just to kind of like in
general like on some like on some Street
[ __ ] yeah or even just like if you're
some [ __ ] you know people are just I
always tell people
don't wear no [ __ ] jewelry yeah it's
really worth it like you know what's so
crazy um it's funny I'm glad you said
that I got a project coming out top of
January it's called the LA handbook
everything that you're asking me it's
crazy I'm so glad you said that because
I got a seven track project which Stills
it's called La handbook and it's from
one through seven telling you what to do
and what not to do
you know leave the sprinters at home if
you can get a Prius get like four or
five Priuses
um take the chains off [ __ ] put the
chains under there tap them with some
[ __ ] that really got some pool in the
city whether it be the neighborhood
[ __ ] the gangster [ __ ] the Bloods
essays whatever you got to do make sure
that you tap and pay your dudes because
that's the that's the type of culture
that we got out here if you ain't
banging
uh cause [ __ ] will get you man well
anything else in the LA handbook that's
important
um so far just the sprinters and the
chains
um definitely
watch out what hat you're wearing watch
what hat you're wearing don't come out
here flagging that out of town [ __ ]
unless you tapped in with the like say
you from I'm gonna just make up Hood
because I don't want to say anybody's
Hood like say with some [ __ ] called
42nd Street villains you know let's just
you y'all [ __ ] know where I'm getting
at 42nd Street villains and you from the
Seattle Branch don't come to California
just thinking that you know oh I'm from
42nd Street villains out there I should
be good out here no you gotta tap in
with the 42nd Street villains in
California make sure that your thugging
is right and your politics is right
before you move around because [ __ ] you
could be over for you you could pull up
to your show and get [ __ ] up
could you bypass everything
by just checking in with Swifty blue
[Laughter]
[ __ ] was about to come up man would you
go online you could just you could print
the certificate right and shout out to
Swifty great guy I love Swifty I just
I'm just curious Swifty is a [ __ ] is
a genius genius of that was the best
because like once the website went up
and like you could print a certificate I
was like oh this guy's a [ __ ] genius
he's done he's done no he's [ __ ]
intelligent no obviously [ __ ] you got
to tap him with the right people but
Swifty might be I don't know like I'm
not a South cider so right and I got
respect for Southsiders I'm half Mexican
so some of my family members are
Southsiders um but that's not my
politics so I wouldn't know what to know
how to yeah I wouldn't know how to go
about that and I got nothing but love
and respect for the South Side um but me
I run my program with the Crips so